as an animator you never really know
what you're doing you it's it's about
being a student it's about learning
and even after doing this for
a few years on my part or okay a few
decades
uh you never stop learning and i hope
you will always
feel that way as well because
when you think like you will have
arrived it sort of stops for you you
know this whole business is about
learning
experiencing life and putting that into
your work anyway the bronze medal honors
this year go to a film from a school
whose animation work has also been
rewarded in the past at these awards
made at brigham young university by
filmmaker jed henry this film is titled
kites
please welcome our animation bronze
medal winner jed henry
it's heavy
we make movies so that we don't have to
stand up in front of people so thank you
academy
for making me stand up in front of
people
um
i'm really grateful to the academy for
getting us here and recognizing our work
i think we all share something the
people who receive awards tonight
and that thing is that we persevered
through a long production time not
knowing if anybody would
would um
be willing to be our audience when we
came out of it and the film was done and
it's a big comfort and a big
encouragement to know that um
just to see you people see this film
tonight um
i just want to thank some people price
it down and get this thing going again
but um
brigham young university's animation
faculty kelly loosley
and ryan woodward
cynthia oberman
brent adams and john reinhardt i think i
saw you out there
i want to thank my wife
who for the 18 months of this film's
production
put up with late nights in a computer
lab and
and motivated me when
i didn't feel like
working on it myself
i also want to recognize a couple of the
students who worked on this film i
saw blake johnson is here tonight
liz richards and andy erickson who
worked really hard
and i'm glad that it's paying off in
their lives and the experiences that
they had on this film
and
like kibum chung i want to thank god
i feel like i've been led to this moment
and i thank him for that and i say these
things thank you
you